voodoo Words phase Japan Thank you to everyone all over the world for
watching adreno and especially for Japanese customers.
Boo Boo s Ale was announced, but
please introduce the surfer with the purity special goods on the stage
.
Teruo
Ale-Mr. Sakurai talked about various details of Smash Bra this morning, but
this morning  I was lucky enough to have him take the stage, and the interpreter, Raymon
, came with me.
Ah, I
'm full of heart
.  For
sm ladies pg se re not for
hard-fi avons is a game, so let's go home from now on
.
peres enoden Dormer Of course I would like to introduce various
things, but in
fact, is there any message from Mr. Sakurai before the play?
The series of roses may continue, but
I think that there is almost nothing to do so far, I hope
you enjoy it
voodoo
boo boo serebro wien
bereza aleksander to do Well, Mr. Sakurai  He explained various techniques of the fighters so far,
but since Ritori was sold only a little, could you introduce the technique of the demonstration play Davidry this morning over the winter
?
I'll touch it
Arashi Taaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Terusu  Play n
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  As
you know, Ridley may be visited by people who don't know, but
Metroid  It's Samus's nemesis in the series
ignore reforma tendresse
Overall, it's actually very tall compared to other fighters.
Convenience meters are good.
However, especially because the demand for overseas colors was very
high, I decided to enter and practice Ridley
andere her to do our Rufa
Apply Pro.
It's a cruel person overall.
Salt charm the base Sticker to catcher Incheon Sofa Star
Teas
Yone Ma-chan's flow wallet
How Smash Bros. x  There was an adventure mode, and
I used to rub Samus against the wall, but
ander Luther Goodu,
this time I rub it against the ground. Gag the pulse Almond 4
[Music]
Oops.  Away
I'm gart
8 You can also jump in the middle of the throw or take special behavior, so
I think that the improvement will change during the game against Regan Sepone by Jump Pepper Giza
.
8 And Neutral  The special move is to spit out a bullet of flame, but my
brother Shoji part asa Fiber person
You can wear multiple souls if you eat like this.
What's the matter
? Circuit wish game Face Irwitt Niizaki Bonishe
Single upper ng I
'm doing my best I'm doing my best
Buberless Patty is also a special move way I used it differently It's a
return move like this
ns Upspe Showers is also userid cure
direction  It can be changed in 4 directions. On a difficult road, 4 is 100,000 yen
. The angle is a little different between diagonally front and diagonally below
.  However, this is a little special technique.
Meeha asperges are as Abe Yunikua
a Please pay attention to Mario's physical strength gauge pcr some other damen
This technique has a sweet spot and hits directly there.  Then
you can do a lot of damage.
Asra seemed to do It's not good even in the rain
. I think it's easier to hit when there are 4 people.
Insect listing ads Easy header 4 p
superb new doing 4 a
Mirage That's all for Ridley's explanation. Internal examination table Clap shutter
web e II
dare to do
I had Elixir play against each other properly.  Yes,
the voodoo Wiener I don't know if the white arm will be me,
but
I'd like to talk with Sams for the time being. I'd like to talk with a little commentary
are you
doing The stage that was said a little earlier.  Select was first are you do
s eyes Stirrer fluffy dimension r rr Winger spacer t
4 se Fighter
stage kr It's an extreme story tear us apart Arles 4 Slo 3
So skippers
stay
is now scored  Do you understand tbs ching is amazing, isn't it? In
the case of 1 to 1, I decided to display the score as editor. When it reaches zero, it's a
roll.
It's not
a ws, it's a
red lineup
[laughs]
Boober hot
re re ga ah ah I think it's good to reach out,
isn't it really good?
I used to have 1 because damage is applied,
so the lion is higher than when I usually play in a match
nan drdr Viewday
4 Number one mesh away takanome Art pen im side 2
While doing so  It's tied right now, isn't it? Nfc This isn't an angry
liner, and now it's a new item, is
n't it?
The pressure match is thin com It's a
monochromatic one bei 4
part As I said, you can shoot down speedily here
he jers name
Buber various sappa
ime
fefefefefefefu
Efefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe.
Is it okay? Erotic
Gallagher Hama  However, the damage is low, so it's easy to save. To get
rid of it, the ambient aberration stands on the right arm by I have to put on the top
.
You can now adjust the time when you're voodoo r 2 s ear
ender
dme Star 4
Boo Boo s 03 e
Boo Barre Cross
Why do you do that?  Speaking of super-major nursing living environment autumn,
then let's fight with 4 people,
anders Let's play against 300 people.
I'll follow you in the
tea room,
this
isn't it, please give me a roller.
I became this ball as Mario, so I'm a little Mario
.
Actually, I like Mario, right?
Before I went to Idetsu Nishi
Iba voodoo
That's the tower of the beginning of the file Yes
Link is physical strength  However, when there is no accumulated damage, that
Ken p part will not lose even at that time.
Aso Tane Key House nomen serebro
berceuse rs Bar Entity Produce Change
Actually, it has been out since the time of Smash Bros. x, but it has been verified every time.  Ah,
Legend Champion Miha to do
and Ai are wintering in
Japanese, but it's a plan tube, but 8 this time
it's a Poi Poodle in Japanese.
Kuro Iku Uu Aura pw
Dunko When you put them in, they're a little surprised-
I haven't been hoping for a while ago.
That's right, it's amazing that the tower is broken and Shimane's new platform
puts in Parao Elpara.
Yes,
I took a picture of a young bald person as well as a carer.
Registration is 8 This time, the power transmission is 3 kilos. That's right. You can now attack any of them.
I've done it.
The blow of the cherry blossoms that are coming is strong. Opalary
sender
Boo Boo Yarn Nou
That damage and the match time are long.
It wasn't good, isn't it?
Katsu This is a local noa from this year.
Hmm re you doing
This is
Ganondorf.  Isn't it fair, isn't he? It's a
tethered guy, it's sleepy, isn't it? It's
bad
render
.
Ah
krauser Good party barrel
voodoo Markets Anyelli Patty
Betty me Bar edge I think that what will happen to Firmidori's Meebo after all
san abc tips
Reeder eme barbie with up cherry 1  Blooming matter By all
means that day, but yeah and the new ink ring army borderless of the Etos muffler series
I saw the Ridley part three-dimensional object for the first time in the forefront  the first to do I
've been watching this since I was making the theory, but the Hamin reindeer
action and
guarder pot type there,
where it differs from the previous Incling Amigo,
the triangular position of the meter on the tank behind here  It's different
render are ready to do
It's a splash one more hit buf to do
jfa snmp agent special 6 Drunk fist --- The user is already at the
star first staff place
voodoo Well, I can't show the real thing today.  In the video,
dg was introduced as Peach's dash fighter, but
I will prepare a daisy for the Smash Bros. series Amivo.
Let's noun
Buzz, I
'm
sorry I can't reach this thank you den o
Well then, I've talked about the Pink League
, and I'll go on the stage for inking.
Feet That's right
2 t Driver
[Music]
Someone in cream should be mixed Navy-sama Goon is okay
Ah
Rain Londonman's catcher
[Music] Is
it okay with Bowser? My
sister is a consultation spike, but with a blue adult  I'm not a kid,
enteritis and Akatsuki Burger Steel, a sharp heart, Lee Sperry enter, because
it's a big deal, ipo noa
Until now, the Zelda series was the starting lineup from the same series. This time, I was
able to change it to my stomach, so
I chose each of the 8 favorite places.
It's a step underwater for rescue w
Paspider Two Setter live design
Boo Boo sf
dere
Goodbye Goodbye
That smash ball and uh fake smash baume
I like it, but this is an
8 cross shape etc.  You can check it with rr sanders Paper Eddie
Oh,
well, it's a detective,
that's the real Bessa,
pse north 4 aab
is good,
it's good, it's crying, isn't it?
Kana and
darker
wres I don't want to make the whole thing.
Oops,
the characters painted on this cream are
accumulated. Be careful because the amount of beige cabal and the amount of damage to Chiba will increase.
[Music]
taroro
I can't do it uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
re re re re re dermalab property
Is there any last word from Mr. Sakurai before the end
? Well, I think that the character was out now, but this is using 3 good
versions.
I think that it will be possible to go around in various places including Japan
. It is
still under development and is being tied up and adjusted.
I'll continue, but um, and I'll be introducing more and more striped bras for the
last three days,
but next is 8 ok
.  After
that, we will cross a special guest Matty, so please continue to support us
[Music]